now yesterday in the first of his Tanner
lectures professor Chakrabarti examined
Karl Jasper's conception
consciousness a self conscious
experience of living in special liminal
or culminating times and he began to
revise this conception as it might apply
to our present thinking on climate
change by the end of his lecture
professor Chakravarthi had mooted a
decentering
of the human itself from the heart of
Anthropocene thinking how might this
decentering be set in motion what might
its effects and dilemmas be please join
me in welcoming back professor de peche
Chakrabarti
so thank you Gary and thank you all for
being here in my lecture yesterday I set
up a couple of distinctions between what
I call a homo centric view of the world
versus Zoe centric
a life centric view of the world and the
distinction for our purposes that I was
trying to signal by using the two words
that mean the same thing homo and
anthropos but I was trying to use them
as a non identity that there is for them
not to mean the same thing and which was
an artificial distinction but today I'll
be working my way through these
distinctions to to kind of further
define this problem of epical
consciousness that I'm both boring and
divisive in my lectures so when we think
of climate change as as representing a
climactic point in the history of
capital or of globalization global
warming appears to be entirely a matter
amenable to issues of inter human
justice even as we acknowledge that
anthropogenic climate change affects
life beyond human life an impact on the
inanimate world as well as OE centric
view is passed over in favor of a homo
centric one consider for instance the
following passage that occurs early in
an otherwise the engaging discussion on
a possible political theory of climate
change in Steve vanderheiden's book on
atmospheric justice it begins with what
you will recognize following yesterday's
discussion with the Zoe centric position
on the climate crisis and I'm quoting
this is how he begins the book it's a
kind of a rolls iam exercise
in normative thinking in terms of
Justice Whittaker climate change carbon
is one of the basic building blocks of
life on the planet Earth with co2 the
dominant means by which carbon is
transmitted between natural carbon sinks
including living things in an exchange
known as the carbon cycle sorry humans
and other animals take in oxygen through
respiration exhale co2 while plants
absorb in stores sold store co2 emitting
oxygen and keeping terrestrial life in
balance Vanderheiden acknowledges that
without the greenhouse gases and the
natural greenhouse effect the planet
would be inhospitable cold for life in
general
and for human life in particular while
some life he writes might be possible to
sustain within a small range of
temperature variability beyond that seen
since the last ice age the climatic
equilibrium produced by 10,000 years of
greenhouse gas stability he's
responsible for the development of all
terrestrial life and even changes from
that equilibrium could through these
equals those ecosystems dramatically out
of balance yet in spite of fully
acknowledging that the climate crisis
concerns the balance of all terrestrial
life on the planet whatever such balance
might mean and therefore needs to be
thought in terms of at least thousands
of years vanderheiden's questions of
justice and iniquity circle around
problems of human life and human life
alone and problems that are actionable
only on the much smaller scale of human
measures of time as he himself says
while an through and this is voting
while anthropogenic climate change is
expected to visit significant and in
some cases catastrophic harm on the
planets non-human species he
acknowledges that but then says his
pursuit of issues of
justice would follow the ipcc in
focusing exclusively as he says on the
planets human habitants habitats and
populations Vanderheiden gives a good
practical reason for this approach and
he says we do not yet know how to
compose a global climate regime that
would include representation for animals
and future generations not to speak of
non animal life life forms or even the
inanimate world he refers to the work of
the political theorist Terrence ball to
argue that even if we represented those
groups by proxies in democratic
institutions giving at least some voice
to their interests they would
necessarily remain a legislative
minority thus it is acknowledged on the
one hand that global atmosphere is a
finite good and it is so not just for
humans for it is vital for the
continuation of life on this planet
quoting while being instrumental for
human flourishing as well while it is
acknowledged and this is the technology
of the lesson of the sciences and yet
when it comes to just disabled issues of
inequality with regard to climate change
the absorptive capacities of the this
one atmosphere which again is
acknowledged that it must be shared
technology is something to be shared
between all of the planet's inhabitants
ends up in the book getting divided up
only among humans and the tortoise in
the book in a lot of the literature the
world's nation that our citizen does he
calls them with no discussion of what
might be the legitimate share of
non-human forms of life from here it is
only a step to forget non-human life all
together and declare global warming to
be synonymous with issues of human
justice and as something that cannot be
remedied until issues of human justice
are satisfactorily addressed I'll read
out a paragraph where you will see
there's a transition initially he he
actually says it is also a problem of
justice
but then actually ends up by saying it
is a problem of justice and its solution
is conditional on the justice question
being addressed
so consummate reading accouting concern
for equity and responsibility should not
be dismissed as secondary to the primary
goal of avoiding catastrophic climate
change for anthropogenic climate change
is also a problem of justice and then so
cannot be genuinely remedied unless the
international response aims to promote
justice and then the last sentence says
global justice and climate change are
manifestations of the same set of
problems if I had to illustrate in this
context a completely opposed point of
view what I might call a Zoe centric one
I would probably cite a statement from
James Lovelock spoke the vanishing face
of Gaia in a chapter entitled the
climate forecast LeBrock argues for the
need to consider and I'm quoting to
consider the health of the earth as a
living planet without the constraint
that the welfare of humankind comes
first this way he explains I see the
health of the earth as primary for we
are utterly dependent upon a healthy
planet for survival we know what
Lovelock means by a healthy planet it is
where Gaia remains in charge that is a
planet where life acts as a self
regulatory system and plays a role in
Maine in maintaining planetary
conditions conducive to the continuation
of life in the language of his Gaia
hypothesis I'm putting the Earth's
atmospheric composition is kept at a
dynamically steady state by the presence
of life moreover if organisms could
affect atmospheric composition they may
be then maybe they could regulate the
climate of the earth to keep it
favourable for life and good now
Lovelock's Gaia theory has faced many
criticisms including some very famous
ones from Richard Dawkins
when Doolittle that life this life
thought of as a planetary scale
phenomenon is almost an indefinable
metaphysical categories acknowledged by
many in fact just that life is hard to
define his acknowledged by most
biologists is acknowledged by many
including Lovelock himself toby Tyrael a
professor of Earth System science at the
University of Southampton has recently
published a book aiming to be a serious
refutation of the Gaia theory while
acknowledging that many of Lovelock's
insights do not
maybe his whole theory are accepted
today as part of normal science it is
not necessary for our purposes either to
rehearse here the details of the
scientific debate around Gaia or even to
take sides in this debate suffice it to
note that Lovelock's comparative work on
the question of presence of life or
absence of life on mars and earth gave
rise to a fascinating question and the
question was why has this planet the
earth has been why has it been so
consistently and continuously hospitable
to life for billions of years and to
multicellular life for hundreds of
millions of years how has oxygen been
maintained at a constant level around
21% of the atmosphere for a very very
long period any more oxygen and life
would go up in flames
any less a lot of life would die of
suffocation this is what led the
geologists young Dallas Civic and Mark
Williams to call the earth the
Goldilocks planet the argument being
that Mars Mars has weather including
spectacular planet-wide dust storms
it might even harbor a few more simple
microbes but it will never be green in a
pleasant land or that Venus starting its
life with probably about as much water
as the earth possesses suffered runaway
planetary warming so earth is the
Goldilocks planet it has been as they
say for far so far and for and all in
all just right for life not just right
for any one time but
Dean useless so for three billionaires
there of course been some very close
calls times of mass extinction but life
is always clung on to bloom once more
that makes the Earth's history more
remarkable then they say any children's
story not everyone is convinced that it
is actually a good question to ask as to
why the earth has been so continuously
friendly to life over such a long period
of time the question some scientists
point out seems natural to us humans
because as complex creatures with big
brains we can come only at the end of a
long line of continuous evolution of
life so sometimes the parallel they give
is you know imagine somebody a whole
bunch of cyclists cycling as top speed
the only place I can imagine here is a
place called gardulla impossible to
negotiate in Banaras in India and and
suppose 100 cyclists start off in 91 and
99 of them are actually killed by
accidents but this knowledge is not
known to the lone survivor so the lone
survivor can get to the other end
anything now what was it that made it
possible for me to continuously exist
through this passage and so they say
look it may have been just a great fluke
that life life actually survived for
some time but to us it seems a natural
question to ask because life culminates
is in us at the for the present and
therefore it seems like a wonderful
question to ask that's why it survived
for such a long time but life the
passage from the very first instance of
life to us may have been just a matter
of enormous luck we are here so it
happened given the number of solar
systems overall some you know 10 to the
20 to 10 to the power of 22 times which
is actually an older estimate what else
could you expect Michael Drew's the
history Stern of science says on the
other hand some geophysicists like my
colleague rapier whom bottom I mentioned
in the last lecture he does not think
that the success of life on this planet
is just a gigantic fluke but admits that
the jury is out on the habitability
problem
some others with reason say that we need
to study more earth-like planets with
similar shares of oxygen in their
atmosphere before we can tell what makes
the planet so welcoming of life as to
evolve complex intelligent species that
can formulate and contemplate this very
problem but nothing can be said on the
basis of a sample size of one it
wouldn't have daunted any historian but
scientists have this problem tobe Tyrael
who is critical of the idea that Gaia
behaves like a homeostatic super
organism protecting life under all
circumstances and a lot of people are
critical of that idea settles for a
position he shares with Andrew Watson
who for those of you know who know la
blocks work was actually once la blocks
collaborator in developing the Daisy
worlds model the black and white daisies
it's how he was just trying to justify
Gaia to scientists but anyway but Toby
Tyrael actually shares with Andrew
Watson the view that the fact the planet
has never snuffed out life completely
since life began is so they kind of
share the pond with this this could be
ascribed to a combination of both luck
and environment stabilizing mechanisms
all beat mechanisms they do not work all
that well so you what you have is a very
modified Gaia that there are mechanisms
that stabilize the atmosphere but they
don't work all that well they're
precarious and they can be jeopardized
the climate crisis that thus raises very
different very significant questions
about the conditions for life on the
planet and invites us to see humans in
that context this is what I have called
the Zoe centric view of the world but we
cannot get to this point of view through
the homo centric per capita emissions
figures of the climate justice
literature the relevant figures here are
not those for per capita emissions but
the story of the expansion of the human
species on the planet up to a point
where we become indisputably the most
dominant species putting pressures on
other life-forms
and the nut scholar Rob hing evils work
explains the problem nicely for most of
our existence your human existence
humans fitted into a pattern of life
where one life forms waste where
resources for another life form and life
subsisted on this natural process of
recycling of wastes now he says thanks
to our numbers and the sale of our
production and the scale of our
production consumption we produce a lot
of waste that cannot be decomposed or
recycles and the two examples are
familiar ones plastics and excess carbon
dioxide at the same time our dependence
on plentiful and cheap energy present is
applied by fossil fuels has become
unavoidable as managing a population of
the size of ten to 12 billion expected
by the end of the century or even the
present 7 billion people
calls for the creation of complex
organizations that produce an ever
increasing demand for energy so just
want to show you some figures from a
paper by Bill Stephan who actually was a
collaborator Paul kids could send wrote
that one of the authors of the great
acceleration paper and been working on
the history of the Anthropocene in some
degree so I'll just show them one by one
just population curve I'll come back to
the figure 1950 I mean their argument
has been that it's really since the
1950s that there's been very sharp
exponential rise and that's urban
population and it's I mean India expects
in a few decades to have more than 10
mega cities just India alone and this is
primary energy use so fossil fuel and
interestingly that little kink up there
is I think the 73 oil crisis doesn't do
very much the relatively recent growth
of the human population is connected to
the story of fossil fuel whether we look
back on human history or anticipate our
futures after all it was fossil fuel
energy and I'm quoting an only fossil
fuel energy that made it possible to
break with the old agrarian pattern
and construct the industrial world
rights the Peak Oil theorist John
Michael Greer but this is the point that
has also been made by John McNeil and
William McNeil that the kind of
deliberating force that the person feels
were in our history in terms of history
of so-called free labor the benefits for
humans of plentiful and cheap energy
derived from fossil fuel have been
innumerable who'd improved both in
quality and quantity improvement in
housing and clothing more hygienic and
healthier conditions in many places
public safety better policing and better
illumination the exponential growth
growth both of human population and our
average lifespan in the 20th century and
here of course the poor are included in
these estimates have generally had much
to do with fossil fuels through the use
of artificial fertilizers pesticides
pumps for irrigation and the use of
petrochemicals in the manufacture of
such common pharmaceutical products as
antibiotic medicines emerging powers
like India and China justify their
continuous use of coal the most
offending fossil fuel and increasing
emissions by referring to the needs of
the to raise billions of Chinese and
Indians out of poverty this is not
simply a story of carbon emissions it is
also about the pressure that humans as a
species exert on lives of other species
and thus ultimately on our conditions on
our own conditions of life and the issue
is not unconnected to the climate
question for as many scholars have
pointed out the warming of the
atmosphere in the seas not only raises
sea levels threatening coastal
settlements cities and Islands it
actually also changes marine
biodiversity by making the sea more
acidic so in an interesting way I mean
the argument what are having become a
geological force
he's also connected to our becoming a
dominant species because by warming the
oceans we begin to affect the
biodiversity of the seas which then has
an impact another another life forms
including ours so in a way that the
climate crisis requires us to think of
it through physics which is the warming
hypothesis
this through geology as well as through
biology these things are completely
connected and as Vaclav SMIL has pointed
out humans and animals they eat and have
made the point in other places now
consume around 95% what the biosphere
produces and the poor are a part of this
species life of humans even while it is
true that they don't they don't bear
much responsibility for the mission of
renounce gases the interesting thing is
that the more people we have on the
planet even if the majority of them are
poor the more complex our societies
become for the administrative apparatus
needing needed to manage managing
populations also correspondingly in
large and ramify and therefore the
greater is the amount of free energy
that these administrative apprentices
themselves need so even if you have a
very country like India where most
people are for practical purposes poor
just managing the population means the
creation of a bureaucracy which will
actually consume a lot more energy if by
the end of the century we have 11
billion humans as predicted will need
even more than we have today of cheap
and plentiful energy to sustain such a
population no less not less the Duke
University geologist Peter have recently
argued that technology becomes enmeshed
with biology and he's put forward a
suggestive concept of the Technosphere
in defining the world we now inhabit so
modern civilization and its present 7
billion human constituents he argues
could not survive without the
proliferation of technology across the
globe the set of large-scale networked
technologies that underlie and make
possible rapid extraction from the earth
of large quantities of free energy and
subsequent power generation
long-distance communication the
including regional continental and
global distribution of food medicines
and other goods this network technology
is supplying the conditions of
possibility for the existence of so many
human lives is what he calls the
Technosphere so in a sense he's saying
that our lives are so intimately the
biological lives are so intimately
connected to the technological connect
divet II that we might as well regard
ourselves as the sentient part of the
Technosphere so without the support
structure and the services provided by
technology he actually produces some US
population statistics to suggest that
the world population without this
connectivity would crash to something
like 11 million
he says technology he argues therefore
represents the opening phase of a new
paradigm of Earth history having become
the precondition for the existence of a
very large number of you very large
human population and for the animals
that humans consume technology therefore
he says can be considered the next
biological frontier it is as if the
legacy of Gaia thinking as Latour puts
it in his characteristic his
characteristic witticism and i'm goating
is to have forced every one of us to
render explicit the growingly technical
conditions for breeding that we require
now out of the suffocating archaic past
he says running towards an otherwise
suffocating future it is at this point
that some familiar themes regarding the
finitude of the planet suggest
themselves the whole question of you
know the whole literature about finitude
where will the energy come from where
will food come from how many planets do
we need luck to actually provide some
fascinating statistics here and he
actually says that that relevant figures
he says that and the figures he's hide
from geologists that human civilization
is already powered by around by around
twelve terawatts so tara is 10 to the
power 12 watts if the world were to be
developed to the point of u.s. levels of
consumption the energy count would go
200 terawatts a figure that latter
rightly describes a stunning if one
considers that plate tectonic forces are
said to develop no more than 40 terra
watts of energy
besides that at letour we will need five
more earth sized planets
to find the necessary global hectares to
support this population at the u.s.
level of consumption setting his sights
somewhat lower
Vaclav SMIL again says if the billions
of poor people in low-income countries
were to claim even half the current per
capita harvest prevailing in affluent
economies too little of the Earth's
primary production would be left in it's
more or less natural state so there is
obviously a case for climate justice yet
Dusty's arguments are not very good at
thinking limits arguments of climate
justice based themselves on per capita
emissions on the Democratic humain but
homo centric assumption that every human
being has equal rights to the world's
carbon sinks that the developed nations
have so far monopolized for themselves
the popularity of this position was
reflected for instance in what the
Indian Environment Minister said in an
interview to the New York Times
September last year placing the
responsibility for what scientists
called the coming climate crisis on the
United States the world's largest
historic greenhouse gas polluter he
actually says when he was asked by the
reporter he said about India cutting
greenhouse emission they said what cuts
that's for the more developed countries
the moral principle of historical
responsibility must apply it would be at
least 30 years before India would likely
see a downturn in the emissions he said
our first task is an easy dedication of
poverty 20% of our population does not
have access to electricity and that's
our top priority will grow faster and
our emissions will rise period zowie
centric views on the other hand do not
think as so much in terms of per capita
emissions of it as of humanity as a
species a dominant one among other
species and therefore the size of human
population matters there are climate
justice thinkers who try to reconcile
the two and create what they call a
contraction and convergence scenario
whereby humans attain a state where all
nations are equally developed the richer
nations of today having learned to
reduce their levels of consumption in
affluence and we're all humans try to
truehl for their overall numbers and
their total resource consumption but
here again calendars demands that are
severely mismatched the calendar for
attaining distributive justice between
humans with regard to the atmosphere is
basically an indefinite calendar we
don't know when and how using the
inevitable hybrid mixture of normative
and politically realistic events that
make up the actual stuff of politics the
world will become more just but the IPCC
presents us with a very definite and
finite calendar for global action if
dangerous climate change were to be
averted and that is if an average rise
of mode of more than 2 degrees Celsius
were to be averted so as to be jeweled
Hooksett we have now just in terms of
the rate of emissions going up we have
already caused it to rise to nearly 400
parts Millions they actually gone past
400 parts per million last December was
three times three ninety four point two
eight was 396 0.8 one in December 2013
three ninety eight point seven eight in
December 2014 and four hundred point one
eight in the week of February with one
this month and the rate of increase is
accelerating the speed at which we are
adding carbon dioxide to the atmosphere
is probably unprecedented he says during
the last 50 million million years or
more the chances of limiting the
temperature rise to 1.5 degrees which
was actually the equivalent of 350 ppm I
think or two degrees Celsius at the
present rate of emissions declined to
66% in six and twenty one years for
those two figures and to 50 percent in
ten and twenty eight to ten ten and
twenty eight point four years
respectively but even this calendar may
be too optimistic the planet has warmed
by 0.8 degrees Celsius above the
pre-industrial average already remarks
by Hamilton and cautions that the
inertia in the system means that two
point four degree Celsius is already
locked in
heating reaching and this other
scientists I have read enough also said
with heating reaching four degree
Celsius perhaps by 2017 and four degree
Celsius rise is uncharted territory so
if you go on the on the web and look at
maps of the world for four degree rise
you will see that the continents have
changed their shapes somewhat so the
Justice calendar and the calendar for
global action spelled out by the IPCC
probably will not meet which means that
our search for climate justice and it's
at endless polit attendant politics may
very well mean that we have to travel
the via dolorosa of dangerous climate
change
perhaps our struggles for climate
justice will have to be carried out in a
world that is even more climate stressed
and far more unjust than the one we have
at present now I come to the Homo
anthropos split so climate changes the
apical consciousness then is constituted
as I have suggested around a split
between Homo humanity as a divided
political subject an anthropos
collective and unintended forms of
existence of the human as a geological
force as a species as part of the
history of life on the planet
the idea of anthropos in this sense
dissenters the human by subordinating
human history to the geological and
evolutionary histories of the planet
recall that Jasper said epical
consciousness is granted to men without
grieving him giving him the rest of a
conclusion to inhabit such consciousness
takes stamina he wrote for it calls for
endurance in the tension of insolubility
and what I'm going to go on to argue by
the end of this presentation is that
what this tension between the Zoe
centric answer eccentric the homeowner
post-split results in it is from where I
am coming to the problem from is a kind
of problem for political thought the
problem for how we think politics and
it's precisely because
political thought is kind of troubled by
these developments that I'm looking for
a form of thinking that allows me to
work more patiently on the problems that
political thought encounters before I
become political so in that was the
sense in which I was looking for a space
before entering politics entering and
being political as well so therefore we
don't have to add this space we don't
have to rush him to Malthusian solutions
or by calculating the carrying capacity
of the planet like a lot of historians
are now turning to those such of efforts
or indulge in generous idols sounding
conjectures of exactly how many people
the planet can actually support there
are current standard of living but in
epical consciousness acknowledges the
moons that drive such thinking and
recognizes them as belonging to a
spectrum of moods the climate crisis
actually creates the Esper's did not
think of epical consciousness
instrumentally as I said as a pragmatic
solution to problems this kind of
thinking he said he's not made is not a
means to the self-preservation of
mankind it would be futile to
incorporate it in a plan
we should always point it but his
existence he said may result in a life
that would by virtue of freedom and
against the Menace of the bomb that he
was the Menace that he was thinking
against save mankind's existence as well
now and this is where he says that he's
at appealing to something that he calls
he made to human beings the capacity for
rationality and I have to say that
because I will reject his position on
this one that his understanding of
rational it is not a naive one so he is
absolutely aware that people can use the
capacity for ratiocination the capacity
for calculated rationality to all kinds
of heinous and selfish ends he also is
aware of the kind of instrumental
rationality that drives technology
developed and she's aware of all of
those thing it's not a so the way he
addresses it let me just work a little
bit with a little bit of a way through
his argument here and when he defines
rationality reason being the true
essence of all human beings he says
which he finds in all human history says
if we distrust reason if we doubt the
human susceptibility reason we have no
faith in man and therefore he also saw
epical consciousness is creating the
common to refuse to give up this chance
so because it was in every man of his
description that I talked about in the
last lecture he says to refuse to give
up this chance of communication between
fellow human beings shows a lack of
faith in man as man and Seitz nature to
say the truth begins when there are two
so this idea is very much that okay know
it leads to communicative relationship
you know between people reason belongs
to man as such it can grow in anyone who
thinks honestly patiently and
unselfishly and reason has the potential
to create a human Brotherhood that could
stand above and beyond the narrow
feelings of group solidarity etc so in
the tradition of thinking that we are
all ears
yes pers has not been alone in finding
in reason and in humans capacity for
taking a planetary global perspective a
real potential for humans Humanity
consciously taking on the role of an
intelligent species that managed this
planet for the benefit of all including
nonhumans in the 20th century non
Imperial or anti-imperial thinkers like
rabindranath tagore Franz fanon and
others have had similar thoughts the
traditional hybrid is older in a recent
essay Deborah Cohen has drawn our
attention to Edward suus the 19th
century Viennese liberal politician who
was also a pioneering scholar of geology
and who actually coined the term
biosphere viewing geology as a subject
that could help combat narrow tribal
affiliations of humans and she has a
lovely quotation from so is actually
saying that if you think me you become
big if you think small if you think
nation you become national if you think
the planet you become planetary within
my own field this assumption that
thinking on large scale leads to a sense
of human solidarity and or global
citizenship has found a resurgent
expression in a branch of historical
that now calls itself big history in the
hands of it one of his pioneers David
Christian the history of the human
species merges seamlessly with the
history of humanity and he writes in
this expanded form history will allow
individuals and communities throughout
the world
to see themselves as part of the
evolving story of an entire universe
just as the ones mapped themselves onto
the cosmologies of different religious
traditions understanding this shared
history will help educators generate the
sense of global citizenship just as
nationalist historiography once created
a sense of solidarity within different
nation-states and in his support he
actually cites William McNeill John
McCain's father who was the pioneer of
the world history movement and when he
was the president of the American
Historical Association he made pretty
similar statement on wow how studying
world history can lead to world feeling
the world citizenship and so there's
this meaning this tradition and this is
now picked up in out by other big
historians who also make the same point
that if we do human history on a very
large scale and actually let the history
of evolution that is the history of the
species kind of become as it were
today's humanist history then we somehow
scale up or scale ourselves up as a
subject as historical subject to to a
scale where it's adequate to meeting the
crisis that we face the idea that
humanity is a subject that can project
itself into the world and is capable of
exercising sovereignty over what humans
do as dominant species or the
geophysical force so the idea that we
can as humanity manage our existence the
other modes of existence we have the
geophysical force or the species also
turns up in many other areas or in the
literature and on the climate crisis
there are those who acknowledge the
anthropogenic literature of Google
global warming and yet find the ultimate
solution in some understanding of this
of the specialness of humans in their
capacity to learn in their capacity to
reason which is why I'm going back to
Jasper's point and therefore in their
capacity to plan manage rationally and
the most probably the most obvious
example of this kind of thinking is the
book written by the climate change
journalist mark Lynas who initially
wrote a book called six degrees which
was descriptions of how the world the
planet would change with each degree
rise in temperature that's how his
chapters were organized and the more
recent book is called God species where
he's basically saying we can actually
play God and it's now our rule to
actually play gone and climate
geographers like Elise argues that some
people actually say that the
Anthropocene is an opportunity for us to
finally charge take take charge of the
planet and therefore they define
something that they call the good
Anthropocene as opposed to the the
dystopic
Anthropocene that other people write
about and they've been interesting
debates in New York Times blog and in
The New York Times in Keene and others
on this question of good antipas lean
and bad and to see these ideas find an
echo in Tobey Gerald's book on Gaia but
an echo that reverberates twice so it
kind of hits the wall once comes back
and hits the other wall and goes back
and in the process as a physicist would
say interferes with itself so one the
one hand to be chiral says that that
because our own activities I'm quoting
are already having a great impact on the
natural world and show no signs of
slowing he argues that humans will be
left with no option but to embark on
some degree of active intervention in
and management of the planet he goes
further and adds the reassuring remark
that safely managing a planet is in some
ways analogous to safely managing an
airplane and you know it's a funny
statement because one of the one of the
statements he makes
against Gaia against Lovelock is that
just because the planet has a history
doesn't mean that it was designed and
and you could turn the same argument on
him that the airplane is designed by us
the panic wasn't designed by us and he
actually then goes on to say that we
don't even fully understand the planet
while if your pilot said or
the Alliance said that they didn't fully
understand this instrument you're going
to fly it would be a terrible
proposition so in some ways that's why I
said it's in it a it's a code twice and
he kind of canceled himself out in in
the process it indeed seems fallacious
to think that that homo in our scheme
could take the place of anthropos though
this is what is seen as possible by many
consider a recent statement of the
economist I'm at the same on the climate
crisis and on human responsibility to
other species actually I say to other
life-forms because he's quote as you can
see from Buddha the Great Buddha so and
Buddha wasn't into species but he was
into life-forms sin argues for the need
for a normative framework in the debate
on climate change one that he thinks and
I agree should recognize that the
growing need for energy consumption by
humans if the masses of Africa Asia and
Latin America are going to enjoy the
fruits of human civilization and to
acquire the capabilities needed for
making truly democratic choice in his
terms but he also recognizes that human
flourishing can come at the cost of
other life forms and therefore advocates
a form of human responsibility towards
nonhumans and I'll just read out a
little bit of his argument he says
consider our responsibility towards the
species he uses the word species that
are threatened with destruction we may
attach importance to the preservation of
these species not merely because the
presence of these species in the world
may sometimes enhance our own living
standards this is where Gautam Buddha's
argument presented in suta nepata to
Tanabata becomes directly and
immediately relevant he argued that the
mother has responsibilities toward her
child not merely because she had
generated her but also because she can
do many things for the child that the
child cannot do in the environmental
context it can be argued that since we
are enormously more powerful than other
species this can be a ground for other
our taking fiduciary responsibility one
of the creatures on whose lives we can
have a
for the influencer now you know over
lunch we're discussing this of course
what he doesn't consider is of course
two things one is that we never have a
full list of all the species on which we
may be impacting and people who study if
mass extinction often say that it's
entirely possible for a species to have
existed for us not to have known about
it
and for it to have gone extinct without
contributing to our statistics on
extinction so first of all we don't know
all the species we have anything
impacting on and following go through
this line of thinking he doesn't
consider the relationship to bacterial
forms of life viral forms of you know
life or non-life the intermediate state
which are hostile to us I mean how would
we develop an ethical parental
responsibility for things that basically
can kill us so so could we ever be in a
position to value the existence of
viruses and bacterial hostile to us
except insofar as the influenced
negatively our lives how could the work
of humans either anticipate or reflect
the work as we do also the species where
our history happens as in the case of
all species through processes that are
random and blind in some aspects we see
the problem that distinguishes our
situation from the threat of a nuclear
winter that Casper's faced in conceiving
his idea of epical consciousness a novel
and singular phenomenon shapes our age
planetary climate change something that
humans never had to face in recorded or
remembered history they faced regional
climate changes and other environmental
problems to be sure but something is
profoundly different about our times the
time of human history the pace at which
we tell stories of individuals and
institutions has now collided with the
timescales of two other histories both
deep the time of evolution of life on
the planet and geological time the
lateral histories whose paces we used to
take for granted in telling the human
story in particular the story of human
motives aspirations and the psychosocial
dramas and institutions that make up our
social lives these narratives were all
built on the assumption that the
geological and evolutionary developments
were like a slow and steady sort of
background noise to what went on for
stage which was our history unless there
was a natural disaster that kind of
impacted on us in our own lifetime
however we become aware of that of the
fact that the background is no longer
just a background we are part of it both
as a dominant species contributing to
the devastation that may become the
great sixth extinction event and at the
same time as a geophysical force
changing not only the climate of the
planet for millennia to come but also it
appears ring out the Holocene and
ushering in a new geological epoch whose
proposed name is the Anthropocene this
temporary collapsing of the human and
geological chronologies has not gone
unnoticed by scientists a very recent
publication by the geologist John Dallas
which and his collaborators have been
working to substantial substantiate and
formalize the name of this epoch of the
Anthropocene cites a series of worldwide
and synchronic static graphics signals
so it is fascinating because you know
the argument so far has been that the
entropy seen some people say it started
with the agriculture invention of
Agriculture some people said it started
with Industrial Revolution but what
these people are arguing is that you can
say that a geological period has started
which is true of the whole planet from
the time when you get stratigraphic
signals that are seen chronically world
worldwide you know that are found at the
same time throughout the world so if you
begin with the Industrial Revolution you
will find the signals in some parts of
the world but not in other parts of the
world so they are actually saying when
is the time from which we can say there
are synchronous worldwide stratigraphic
signals suggesting the modification of
the geology of the planet
by Homo sapiens by us so that's the date
they're looking for and interestingly in
in doing that they have they now say
that the Anthropocene and this is more
recent than other news unanswerable
syndrome geologists they say the
Anthropocene has to be defined to begin
historically at the moment of the
detonation of the Trinity atom bomb at
Alamogordo New Mexico on July 16 1945 so
in for a lot of us it's happened in our
living time or just before you know we
came here so in the sense they're saying
a geological so this collapsing you know
if you think of something of the
geological epoch you don't call
something a geological epoch
if you don't assume that it'll be of you
know few million years old right so in a
sense 1945 you can write that as a story
of globalization the great acceleration
and the increase of consumption but they
think this is also the beginning of a
geological epoch so in a way we are
living through a time which is forcing
on us on our kind of forcing on our
attention the fact of geological time
the fact of how geologists think about
period eyes in the world because the
event they say has begun in our own
lifetime with the onset they say of the
Industrial Revolution humankind became a
pronounced geological factor but it was
from the mid 20th century that worldwide
impact of the accelerating Industrial
Revolution became both global and near
synchronous the data's combines both an
important event in human history they
said there was if the date combines an
important event in human history which
is the detonation of the bomb the text
explosion and they say the source of a
chemo stratigraphic global signal if the
Anthropocene is ever formalized by the
International Union of geologists it
will mean that long after maybe fossil
fuel-based civilizations
on the earth will still bear in its
rocks the signs of our having been here
but who is the we who is the we of this
our having been here we are
simultaneously a divided home eccentric
humanity that dominant species have out
of the history of life on this planet
and the geological agent with this
collapsing of multiple chronologies of
species history geological times into
our own very small lifetimes within
living memory the human condition has
changed this change condition does not
mean that they're related but different
stories of humans has divided humanity
as a species and as a geological agent
have all fused into one big story and
one single story of the planet or of the
human life on it can now serve in the
place of humanist history as humans we
have no ways of experiencing as distinct
from cognitively knowing or deducing
from other events these modes of being
there are also open to us today humans
as a species humans as the makers of the
Anthropocene at distinct categories we
construct their archives if you think of
humanity if you think of human species
if you think of humans as a geological
force these are analytically distinct
categories because we construct these
objects with different archives
different research strategies different
research tools different analytical
strategies different skills and you
require different skills to create these
objects even though these objects are
now collapsing in time they're kind of
running into one another
it is obvious that humans cannot live
denying their evolved characteristics
human artifacts will always have to be
designed around the assumption that we
have binocular vision and opposable
thumbs
but having big and complex brains may
very well mean contrary to the argument
that proponents of big history make that
our deep there are they mean that our
big
beep histories can exist alongside our
small and shallow pasts that our
internal sense of time will not always
aligned itself with evolutionary or
geological chronology there's a very
interesting question as to why and if
you think of the word human like we see
humans left Africa and went here and
there and why I often think why why am i
using the word human now a few these who
those those humans if they'd invented
writing and left records then would have
probably found little bands moving and
the bands probably would have distinct
one band would have distinguished itself
from another band so it's not like what
we call small recorded history was
impossibly absent or you know totally
absent in that time we can consider a
possibility and so this kind of totally
absurd experiment but the other reason
why we think of them also as humans is
not simply because we don't have the
data but we're also we're also sort of
aggregating a lot of data to say a lot
of these histories to say humans
emigrated out of Africa right but it
means that if those humans had had
written records we would have been able
to combine deep history and recorded
history in very different ways and that
kind of depth so the word human there is
significantly different from the word
human as used in humanist history but
the relatively recent collapsing of
these different scaled chronologies
differently scale per ologies now stares
us in the face
creating a consciousness that I like him
to the effect of falling we have fallen
into big history or at least I have
fallen into big history the falling into
big history carries a certain shock of
recognition recognition of the other
Ness of the planet and it's processes of
which we have unintentionally become
apart so in some people say climate
change is capitalism even my good friend
Nami or risk is writing in Isis recently
said okay climate change can be reduced
to capitalism but surely capitalism is
very important part of it I'm
capillaries there's no question but the
point is capitalism can't decide
what kind of feedback process it would
kick in I mean you can't from within an
analysis of capitalism say that if we if
we take the heating up to three degrees
these are the feedback processes that
are setting the planet decides that it's
other processes decide that and in that
sense the planet remains a co actor in
the in the industry so what do I then
mean by falling now it is somewhat you
can think of falling as falling into
emergency in the been Dominion fashion
that the past like this big paths are
flashing up in front of your eyes
because you've fallen into an emergency
but being from the Indian subcontinent
where diabetes has acquired epidemic
proportions
I sometimes explain this experience by
drawing an analogy with how an Indian
person sense of his or her own past
suddenly under grows a rapid expansion
when he or she is diagnosed is diabetic
so you go to the doctor
with potentially a historians view of
your own past a biography that you could
place in certain social and historical
context the diagnosis however opens up
completely new impersonal long-term
paths that you could not ever own in a
possessive individualist manner so the
doctor might tell you you might tell you
that oh you're from the subcontinent you
people have a propensity to that
diabetes because you've been eating our
rice and then you see our I've been
eating rice from my childhood oh no
because you've been eating right for
thousands of years that's why so
suddenly your history becomes part of
thousands of years and then he might say
and you're a professor you have a
sedentary lifestyle but you were also a
Brahmin so you've been sedentary long
before you become a professor right
that's kind of few hundred years and
then you might say well this particular
gene or whatever and that's kind of
evolution so suddenly you kind of fall
into big history in this in this crisis
written diagnosis I'm kind of likening
the effect of falling it into big
history to that so that's kind of a
situation
such falling into be history is what the
tension in epical consciousness between
the homo centric and the so eccentric
views of the world is about one can
inhabit the tension but not resolve it
for as categories constructed here and
through pause is not homo homo cannot
become anthropos that's been my argument
i accepted yes pers category of apical
consciousness is something that with
revisions may be a fuse as we struggle
to compose the common of the kyoto
formula of common but differentiated
responsibilities but i also found it
helpful to work with Jasper's idea that
such consciousness denoted a thought
space that came before and beyond
politics without however for shortening
the space for political disposition and
difficult differences here i must make a
point that you know i've been taking
part in discussions while i've been here
in it or not the most exhilarating if a
little exhausting part of this
experience has been the discussions that
i've had formally informally with
colleagues here and this morning with
dan over breakfast and then over lunch
and with the history and politics
students and faculty this morning with
literature with students in faculty
yesterday one of the things that became
becoming clear increasingly is that if
you if you look into the biology of
human beings there is being done now the
biology increasingly challenges the
notion of personhood the notion of this
autonomous individual person but a lot
of political thought and political
conceptions of development amarka sense
conceptions of capability that you need
to develop in an individual as still
wedded to a certain kind of imagination
of personhood and that's why i think
this is falling into big history has the
potential to actually create a very
generative productive crisis for
political thought and and that's so i
found it helpful to work with Jasper's
but yes was grounded this consciousness
in reason as i said which is why is the
essence of of human being and of course
reason could not be a satisfactory
solution because reason assumes that
homo can take on the responsibility of
an
propose that we can take on the
responsibility of being a dominant
species or a geophysical force and I'm
suggesting we can't so I had to get out
of this reason business and how do I get
out I was looking for a queue in
Jasper's on proves and the certain point
in his exposition helped me where he
says reason is more than the sum of the
acts of clear clear thinking these acts
rather spring from a basic life carrying
basic mood and it is this mood that we
call reason and when I give a version of
the earlier version of this lecture in
Vienna we had a discussion with Anna and
Stefan on this question and I had a
hunch that he might have used the word
stim
for mood and actually going back to
German text I discovered that the
original word in the German takes his
room still basic mood so clearly there's
an this is obviously a shadow of
Heidegger falling on these sticks even
when he's trying to distance himself and
if you go to Heidegger the national mood
is fascinating in being in time in
elsewhere so Heidegger is thinking about
moods precisely against the tradition
Aristotelian tradition of thinking that
reason comes into play when you can hold
your passions back when your emotions
back the reason or emotions are reason
is effect are opposed to each other and
Heidegger is arguing that we reason with
in ethics that effect is far more
primordial so I won't read out the
couple of hiding passages I have from
Heidegger mainly because if you have not
been reading Heidegger it's just
difficult
it's just platters of the conversation
but heidegger's proposition is that that
the world is disclosed to us he says far
more primordial by mood by effect then
by what he calls cognition which he
thinks falls far short of when he
actually says it is mood demun that
discloses to the being to the to the
existence of the human being it's place
because the beef English guide the word
he uses
that literally means how do you find
where do you find yourself how do you
find the way do you find you so finding
yourself in a place and therefore it's
not a psychological category it's an
ontological category and the English
word mood or the reference to the mind
doesn't quite capture what Heisig is
trying to get at so in some ways
Heidegger is actually saying then that
if we take into account the basic modes
then if you follow Heidegger through and
if we think of this crisis as on the one
hand if you think of the anthropocentric
the homo centric figuration of the
hormone then you can see all the moves
to do with climate change because the
moons are of denial skepticism unbelief
optimism like mark Linus's you can see
all the moons within which you will
argue different positions out but when
you take the Zoe centric view that when
the subject is life when the story is
there of life the subject of life is a
very dispersed subject it's not any one
species
it's summing them one of the things that
we were discussing at lunch time is so
many of our physiological properties are
things that we share with horses and
other animals so when you have when you
when you make life the main part of the
narrative the subject that emerges is
what I'm calling a dispersed subject the
subject that is dispersed over several
life forms and there is no corresponding
politics that you can create that would
correspond to such a dispersed subject
and that takes takes me to the end of
this lecture then so that so in other
words when we when we fall into big
history in my sense which is a kind of
high reg Aryan throne Ness into this
history then to the degree that we are
Homo we can argue from effect from base
basic moves and the basic moves that's
why I will include denial will include
skepticism those are things we have to
take seriously they're also about what
we have invested in fossil fuel and what
we owe to fossil fuel but the other part
of the narrative where life becomes the
main actor
then that then it's a completely
different way of thinking about the
subject and the thinking about the
subject of politics is something that is
still to come we haven't even done the
exercise on that and in a way what you
find is this emerging lag between what
the science requires you to think and
port politics requires you to think and
so therefore let me end here so the
question that arises is if we take into
account the basic moods that underlie
human responses to scientists present at
hand propositions about planetary
climate change there is propositions you
can only get cognitively moves that
range from fear denial skepticism
pragmatism to optimism even of the a new
kind what is the nature of the world not
the abstract concept of the earth but
the lived world the place that is
disclosed where epochal consciousness
finds itself and as I was suggesting
because apical consciousness find itself
in that place where politics is like a
political imagination is lagging behind
what the science is suggesting so to end
we might actually follow Lovelock and
ask will humans even in all their
conflicts and differences recognize the
needs of the earth even if their
response time is slow and we can add to
that another question will the humans be
able to compose a politics that will
correspond to what I'm calling the
dispersed subject correspond the
dispersed subject of life that remains
the critical question of the future how
we answer these questions will also help
our understanding of the word common in
the expression common but differentiated
responsibilities thank you very much
it's a question which is still in
formulation so bear with me a falling
into big history and I take big history
in its reflections on religion which
you've referred to in a quote I think
from David Christensen and you made a he
makes a reference there to cosmology in
the religions meat and to how this can
be placed myths say huh
and it's a passing comment and I'm
struck by how religion is a passing
reference in big history it is not a
focus of the of their own analysis in a
deep analytical sense so I wanted to
visit that in terms of your remarks that
um just as religion removed itself from
cosmology in whatever time period we
might see that I wonder if religion now
returns to the question of cosmology and
this is something I think big history
misses but I think you're moving towards
it in in the realm of effect and mood
that what cosmology in the religious
traditions was exploring let me just say
wonder or awe in all of its psychology
or not and that the role of religions is
not over in this regard in fact the
return to it and let me conclude by
saying I think there will be a papal
encyclical on the environment in June or
July and it will be very interesting to
read that the tenor of mood that that
document releases because I believe the
Paris negotiators are very keen
you yeah thank you no I mean do two
quick responses actually in some ways
again we were discussing that lunchtime
some some types of big history actually
work as religious history in the sense
that saying Christians book what I what
I often didn't understand trying to
follow through its argument is that if
you start with the Big Bang why do you
have to end with humans if you start
with Big Bang's
with the Big Bang why does the story
have to end with us humans it could have
gone any which way I mean there are
multiple things that follow from the Big
Bang it's not just our story that
tumbles out so in in some respects it's
almost human history as God might have
seen it in that structure but that but
the other interesting point that Latour
is Rhetor makes in his Gifford lectures
on natural religion where he talks about
Gaia and he talks about Gaia as you know
the most secular form of religion a
religious cosmology that could be
created and then somewhere I think
thereby he accommodates the need for
religious thinking it's a place for a
certain kind of religious thinking
because that rule has also in other
places a long argument have about how
the world's needs to be reinserted and
not disenchanted so anyway that just the
two remarks I have to make
used yesterday the climate change isn't
departmental it was just really struck
by that time especially in this context
so it's wondering if you wanted to talk
about whether climate change is an
occasion to rethink the structure of the
university in to everything you know the
structure of departments in general well
I mean it's um so that the thought was
the thought was aspirin in the sense
that he was so his argument was that if
you're faced with an extremity like if
you're if you think from the horizon of
a catastrophic danger then specialized
thinking doesn't help because
specialized thinking in effect he argues
takes for granted a kind of stability of
the environment right and and that's why
we were having this discussion as to
whether or not the discipline the modern
disciplines as they have formed have
actually come out of certain shared
assumptions about our relationship to
nature and the stability of the
environment in which we operate so that
you could actually think of humans as
something as separate from their
environment instead of think us as a you
know niche species that sort of lives in
a particular kind of niche you could
think of us as as we can live on Mars we
can go to other planets we don't need a
niche but I think it followed from the
kind of climatic stability but that's
just a thought I'm hazarding I mean you
know nobody has worked on it but clearly
if what I am signaling is the crisis of
crisis of political thought as part of
the history of the present in other
words when one falls into these
histories when one is thrown into these
histories what is what unravels and is
the way one thought of the subject of
politics you know in the discourse of
development in the disco
rights and that unravel somewhat even
though that doesn't mean that it goes
away because there'll be climate
refugees there will be demands that
human beings will make in the name of
those concepts like rights and in
development so that doesn't go away but
it philosophically it unravels and this
space opens up where you kind of
cognitively realize that the subject of
history if we now think of one being
history or one history of evolution that
subjects the dispersed subject there's
no one subject of that history because
there are so many things attributes you
share with other creatures so in a way
in that history that's why he you can
write a world history going back but if
only just a human history or a human
history will go only be a part of a much
larger history of a dispersed subject
and we don't know I mean I think that's
what latitude was trying to work towards
in the politics of nature but we don't
know what what kind of a political
imagination would correspond to that
which is why when I began with this
Rawls Ian person's book on atmospheric
justice I mean he acknowledges that this
is a crisis that will affect all forms
of life but then says that here are the
reasons why we are going I'm not
considering other forms of life I'll
only be concerned with justice between
humans right and that but he doesn't see
this as a crisis of his training but and
what we have to learn to do is to see
these as crisis of our training for the
present times the way in which our
training is inadequate I think you'll
probably happen it's kind of you know I
see movements on the ground every place
I go there is a kind of an incipient
awareness of this problem and in
different institutions I mean today have
we had a very interesting discussion in
the context of this in all institutions
are trying to think at these
institutions where there's been a rich
tradition of thinking politically
thinking political philosophically
thinking through political thought this
is having an impact and that it's it's
it's precisely that that that our having
suddenly to face this fact of falling
short of the present is what I'm calling
falling into because
and that's what I'm calling you know the
history of the present
I take it that one of the things you're
playing out to us is the inadequacy of
of the sort of Andrew Andrew centric
story on its own for addressing our
current condition where it dovetails
with the geological story and cosmos
where and so forth and so this has an
ethical dimension the ethical dimension
and Dale Jameson has has talked about
this Davison yes yeah right and how in
assigning responsibilities we've really
gone about this in an inadequate way and
we have to parse it further and and also
how the ethics these sort of our ethical
background that arose to her I suppose
he means during the actual period is
really inadequate to this task and I
wonder if you you know thought through a
little further than some of us have on
this no no thank you thank you for the
question I'm I will be meeting Dale soon
I'm looking for to hearing him more on
this one one thought that I've taken
away from Dale's work sometimes it's
also their enhanced Jonas's work as to
what creates the condition even just are
talking human affairs not talking human
relationship to others what case the
conditions for human ethicality with
regard to resource consumption and the
argument often is that unless you have a
regime that is asking you to be ethical
it's very difficult for humans to be
ethical in a free-market way and Jay
Dale made that argument sometimes you
know in terms of consumer choice you
know what will what will make Americans
consume less if we if there are products
on the shopping mall shelves where you
can actually buy them and he has an
interesting argument about why that
doesn't work but on the larger question
the
the problem I'm raising in my talk is
that we can be ethical as in tension and
out beings within a limited domain I'm
saying it's very difficult for us contra
what Edward Wilson says and many other
people say for us to take on a
responsibility as a species I'm saying
we we as intentionally endowed humans
with this internal time consciousness
and the way the brain works internally
and with our experience in the brain
creates we cannot take the place or
determine the our actions completely as
a species because because the species
world is much less known we often don't
know what what the chains of causations
are what we are impacting on what will
impact back on us the knowledge is so
incomplete that it's it's really
difficult to have a an ethical project
in there though you can in a limited
manner talk about ethical relationships
in a multi-species
context but with animals and with other
creaturely life usually forms of life
many people have talked about it sort of
donna haraway and others but i'm
actually if my argument is right it's
actually about the difficulty of being
ethical about being a geophysical force
because to me it goes back to a much
more difficult question which is that
which is the question that I formulate
is the question of what we owe to fossil
fuels and it's clear that one of the
things we owe to fossil fuels is even
the increased longevity of the poor and
and it's clear that having so many
people is not necessarily good for other
forms of life I mean that much is
obvious but on the other hand should we
have fewer people how do we get to fewer
people so and that's where I feel
there's a you know when I read people
who actually say there should not be
more than
1 billion people and I can't find a
humane way of getting to 1 million
people I can't find a way of getting to
1 billion people that doesn't doesn't
cause sadness hurt harm death loss of
you know life whatever wound all kinds
of things so when I stand there I don't
have an ethical feeling I really I kind
of stand in front of that question and
the question that actually says to the
welfare is to me the human being in me
it says so we must get more energy if
more people have to survive we actually
need more energy
and then cognitively I know what its
implications are and in that moment I
really experience more like something
like the question of faith more
something like what Kierkegaard
describes as fear and trembling and if
you would regard that as an it as a
dimension of ethics um I'm happy to run
to that position but that that's what I
present experience that's why I can't go
there because my entire training in in
in politics which is a form of care for
other human beings I have not thought of
you know I'm not a Smitty and I haven't
thought of politics is as friends as
enemies I'm always grateful that my
departmental chair doesn't think of
departmental politics is friends and
enemies but but you know I I think of it
as a form of care and to a limited
extent if we extend it to nonhumans no
question but but the problem that's why
I saying the problem is the size of the
population and everybody is pointing to
that everybody is pointing to the
finitude of the planet when people talk
about trace metals that we use in
cellphones and everything and we are up
against a certain kind of finitude which
we're also now part of on an energy or
physical scale so that's why I'm I'm
saying that I'm these are my my
predominant effect is of being through
that typical high daguerreian thrown
into it and if you and the closest I get
to an ethical position is that of fear
and trembling
but thank you for a couple of ripping
lectures so I'm very fascinated by this
crisis of political theory that you
point out sorry the last I'm fascinated
by the crisis of political theory that
you point out especially the subject as
a dispersed subject and I know this
might be asking you to reaching it but
to reach into the future because you
said that there is no imagination of
what the political might look like if we
accept you know these species based sort
of ideas of now I remember reading in
habitations of modernity where you
talked about how the post-colonial in
the post-colonial subject reason and
emotion cohered in a way to make him or
her somewhat of a hyper-rational
schizophrenic subject and in some of the
personal forms of subjectivity yeah and
I wonder here if we are going to eclipse
our rights-based ideas of politics but
still retain them in our claim making
then whether you know this alternative
politics or this new politics that you
are trying to get at might also be
somewhat schizophrenic in certain ways
well I mean again I'm now thinking of
both what I said and thinking back to a
lot of latticework so the I think I'm
definitely describing the current
situation as schizophrenic as kind of
cognitively knowing that the subject of
evolution is dispersed but politically
hanging on to notions of autonomy
personhood capability all of those
things if not me then governments our
nations are in a World Bank is right and
I like so in some ways the obvious
outdated Ness of that political thought
when looked at cognitively but at the
same time the
the absolute at the moment
indispensability of that thought in the
absence of anything else is what leaves
you for me it is precisely that problem
that leaves me asking my reader for the
permission to create a space in which I
think patiently before I jump into the
political fray and that's what apical
consciousness is for me is all about
it's really saying it in that sense I'm
asking for a space before I become
political because I am already always
political I'm trying I'm asking for
permission to create that space in which
I contemplate the possibilities here and
join others like latter and others
almost everybody in this room as to
because that's what i think we have to
think we have to think that if the
subject of history and now I'm talk
about history world history not as human
history but world history as the history
of life and if the subject of that life
is a dispersed subject how do you think
of governance how do you think of
culpability I mean today this question
came up in the discussions with your
group you know if we can think of
ourselves as an abstract as abstract
labor or abstract commodity or as a
bearer of abstract commodity
labour-power whatever why can't we think
of us we'll just imagine us what that
species being a species right now the
interesting thing is that we have an
administrative set up a governing set up
that actually deals in those categories
right so fair wage equal wage for equal
pay for equal work is actually precisely
working that logic of equivalence out
right so so there are administrative
ruling structures that are actually
ruling through those categories so it's
in a in a you know kind of what Ian's
hacking one's called you know
interactive nominalism or something like
that you can identify with that
structure by which the administrative
doctor calls you so the administrator
hails you as a professor at the
University of Chicago or at Yale
University and you respond to that call
but there is no administrative structure
that calls you to play the part of
species
it and that's precisely then the
political task you know can recreate
what lateral composing the you know the
the Parliament of things and non things
or whatever the expression is so you
need a structure of governance that is
actually administering justice but
administering justice for a very
dispersed subject in in weather so the
fundamental question may be do we need
political thought do we need something
else to do the work of political thought
right and that's that's where I'm left I
mean it's again I don't have finished
answers for you mainly because as I said
I mean what I'm trying to do this work
is to work around the idea of falling
into the history work around the idea of
being thrown into big history precisely
because as I said that it was just you
know some years before I was born that
the Anthropocene began if the geologists
theory is going to be accepted so this
collapsing of really what we would
regard as modern shallow human history
and the beginning of a new period
ization of deep history this is
collapsing of these two is what creating
you know and then the sixth great
extinction possibly happening in our
lifetime
right and it's these sort of these these
chronologies sort of coming together
mainly because we have through co2 and
other things through capitalism put a
spanner in the works of the rot systems
and but that spanner has suddenly
revealed to us certain facts which were
not unknown to specialists and that goes
back to again whities question so the
the facts which were once only the
preserve of specialist studies have
somebody sort of circulated back into
general discussion in the public sphere
right and for which we were not prepared
by our training and what i'm trying to
do and many others are trying to dance
trying to do other survive to do is to
actually then see what in our training
we can mobilize to
address the situation even if only to
describe it even if only to sort of
delineate a predicament out of which
hopefully something will come